so our work on question-answering
focuses on providing the capability for
human user to ask for information in a
very natural way the same way that they
would ask a human assistant for
information
it's actually built up of several
fundamental algorithms that we work on
in the language Technologies Institute
so the first thing you have to do is to
analyze the users question and
understand what they're asking for at
the level of the underlying meaning
rather than just the words that they're
using so that involves doing work on
what we call natural language parsing
then we have to search for the relevant
documents or information resources that
we can use to answer that question and
that involves algorithms in indexing and
retrieval or search engines which is
another you know big part of the
research that we do here at the LTI then
we have a step where we take those
documents that we've retrieved and then
we try to extract the candidate answers
for the question
which involves the field of information
extraction which is yet another
component technology that we work on
here in the LTI and then finally we have
to combine all of the candidate answers
together and reason about what is you
know sort of the best answer you know to
provide to the user so when IBM was
considering whether to mount this
Jeopardy challenge and really try to
apply their question answering
technology to this very challenging you
know real-time question answering
problem they got in touch with us
because they knew that more advances
would be required at the level of the of
the software architecture the Jeopardy
problem is an important challenge for
the field because systems have to
respond much more quickly than they ever
have in the past also the system has has
to have a much better model of its own
confidence in its answers because in the
Jeopardy context you can actually decide
not the answer and wait to hear what the
other contestants give as an answer and
they may be buzzed in and then give a
second answer if you look at the
Jeopardy game requires forms of
reasoning that are quite sophisticated
there's lots of use of metaphor and
rhyming puns puzzles you know these
kinds of games which go beyond just
understanding the meaning of the
language but doing more sophisticated
kinds of you know inference or reasoning
over that so I think you know as a
challenge problem jeopardy really will
stretch the state of the art if we can
come up with a you know system that
really can compete with humans there
so IBM in the long term is planning to
have other organizations you know
participate not only in this you know
jeopardy challenge problem but the other
challenge problems that we've been
developing in the O a QA initiative and
we've already had students from Carnegie
Mellon you know collaborating with IBM
in the future we'd like to broaden that
and we've done question answering in the
class before and I'm looking forward to
you know doing something related to
these challenge problems there in
particular what you can do is you can
focus on one component algorithm of an
agent like a jeopardy agent and improve
the document recall you can improve the
answer quality you can think of
different models for answer confidence
and the whole idea behind defining this
logical software architecture is to make
it very pluggable so if you have a
student who comes up with a bright idea
for how to solve one component of the
problem they can produce a software
module that will plug into the larger
system and then can immediately be
tested to show whether or not it gives
you a comparative advantage you know to
the technology that you have before and
I think what we'd like to do is sponsor
the idea of student teams working
together where they sort of mix and
match and combine different algorithms
and then come up with optimal or you
know best-of-breed solutions you know to
challenge problems like jeopardy